hello and welcome home good right again
why do I have white many white games in
role-playing Sharif oh here in the and
the other current so she doing there is
six hmm it's rare maybe I can put some
immediate pressure on his King side
okay Bishop d3 there's probably night
before that it's not so noise c3 is a
bit lame okay still probably probably
useful
yeah maybe country for was not the best
option taking us the quickest move to
develop here as he cannot take with the
bishop I guess
still cannot play the patient yeah that
that is a hard move to believe Knight
has very good square C 4 and D 6 wonder
Knight a5 has set maybe an option
he wants to go Bishop a 6 ok Bishop
before maybe here
a bishop is six it's not really helping
him I have a guru q1 Bishop c4 Bishop c4
is a tempo undisturbed b'shem and I have
really substantial pressure
[Music]
well
Wow really
[Music]
what is he doing now taking it takes to
success now no never
there is not going to work okay
Bishop g6 is probably the easiest move
let's do it it wouldn't have worked with
something else
a d5 absolutely absolutely won't cut it
okay a Quincy form yeah big bit too
creative maybe I don't think it really
is best c4 or 93 is certainly good this
is just a bad other kinds six doesn't
fit into this position at all making
this [ __ ] up bad okay Quincy form
probably a bit too creative but today it
worked out nicely but not the best yeah
I should take yeah I think if I played
the normal-looking Bishop d3 is going to
take maybe and this is something where
black is okay of course and this is
better yesterday when the pawn and now I
can develop more quickly
you know g6 tough tough to give him
advice how do you get out of this mind
a3 tempo yeah I was thinking night night
a 5-2 train but it gets it gets
problematic now 96 was better already
okay 96 threatening see form you cannot
move the Queen as d5 is just hanging
them yeah it's a disaster a real
disaster I don't really see something
good for him now six Bishop f6 funky
made in such a situation would be Queen
g6 pawn takes Bishop d6 mate but yeah
it's not happening has to take it and
our d5 gives me the points right away
but I don't see him defending this
suggests it's too much pressure
h5 is given as Best Buy
engine yeah I would have gone to age 48
fairly certain
yeah be sure basic the brake is still
alive and it's not lost that's still
fightin yeah this helped no bishop g6
this one of the wins rookie six should
win as well
yeah it's either made as in the game or
yeah Bishop e7 or can just take you over
yeah thanks a lot for watching